Spider-Man: Homecoming has arrived, and it's
far more tangled in the massive web of the
Marvel Cinematic Universe than anyone ever
expected, with references to over fifty years
of Marvel comics.
If the average spider can lay anywhere between
ten and 1500 eggs, just how many Easter eggs
did Homecoming leave behind?
And if your Spidey-sense is tingling, that's
only because there are spoilers ahead.
Damage Control
So, who cleans up after superheroes and their
arch-villains have their mega-destructive
throwdowns all over the globe?
In the comics, that job goes to Damage Control,
a government agency that's been around since
1988.
Marvel's been kicking around the idea of a
Damage Control sitcom since 2015, but the
project never really made it off the ground.
So, while we may never see a Marvel sitcom
a la DC's failed Powerless, Damage Control
has officially made it into continuity…
and Adrian Toomes is not happy.
Betty Brant
Peter Parker's school has its own TV news
program, starring none other than Marvel mainstay
Betty Brant.
Betty first appeared in The Amazing Spider-Man
#4, way back in 1963, as newspaper mogul J.
Jonah Jameson's secretary.
Eventually, she becomes a pretty successful
investigative reporter, and even has a fling
with the Hobgoblin.
She plays a pretty big part in Spider-Man's
life, and a version of her even appeared in
Tobey Maguire's Spider-Man, so it's not unlikely
that she'll figure into the future, in one
way or another.
Spider-Signal
We saw it in Civil War's post-credits scene,
but we see it again when Peter's tinkering
with his suit's devices in Homecoming.
Comic fans all felt a weird tingle when Peter
briefly projected a Spider-Man logo onto the
wall, bringing back comic memories of Spider-Man's
most hilariously useless device.
Contrary to Batman's awesome Bat-signal, which
summons the Dark Knight from great distances,
Spider-Man's Spider-Signal doesn't do much
more than announce his arrival to criminals,
and occasionally act as a flashlight.
Not every idea from the early days of Spider-Man
was a good one.
Those armpit-webs, on the other hand, will
always be pure comic book gold.
Summon the Sinister Six
The appearance of Adrian Toomes, aka Vulture,
definitely isn't an Easter egg, but it probably
takes a real comic fan to spot some of Spidey's
other legendary foes.
While the Sinister Six has taken many forms
over the years, the elderly Vulture has usually
been a core member.
Also pretty prominent in Homecoming is Shocker,
who seems to be whoever's wearing an alien-tech-enhanced
glove.
But the reference to the comics' Shocker goes
twofold when those same guys are seen wearing
the same distinctive, yellow quilted fabric
that the comic villain wears.
"Shockeeeeeeerrrrrrrr!"
"You can't escape me!"
You'll also find Mac Gargan, aka Scorpion,
played by Michael Mando.
In contrast to Homecoming's Gargan, comic
book Gargan started out as an investigative
reporter whose life is messed up by the experimental
process that gives him a giant, mechanical
scorpion tail.
If there was any doubt about these two Gargans
being related, there's also that giant Scorpion
tattoo on big-screen Gargan's neck, too.
We also get a whole lot of Hobgoblin, and
sorry to say, it's Peter Parker's biggest
fan and best friend, Ned.
While his full name is never given, Ned's
last name has been given as 'Leeds' in a few
different publications.
Ned Leeds becomes one of at least seven different
Hobgoblins after being brainwashed by the
original Hobgoblin, Roderick Kingsley, to
take his place.
Let's say that things don't end well.
The Howling Commando legacy
If you think you're seeing a familiar face
at Peter Parker's school, it's because actor
Kenneth Choi is playing his own grandson.
Way back in Captain America: The First Avenger,
Choi played Jim Morita, a member of Cap's
Howling Commandos, a legendary group of Marvel
Comics soldiers originally operating under
Nick Fury.
Choi returned in Homecoming to play Principal
Morita, a guy obviously very proud of his
grandpa, given the photo of Jim that can be
spotted in his office.
Morita Jr. Jr.'s love of history also possibly
explains his affection for those terrible
Captain America instructional videos.
And speaking of cameos in photos around the
school, the Incredible Hulk himself, Bruce
Banner, appears in one of the many posters
of great scientists featured around the science
classroom.
And who's that on the school mural?
Howard Stark himself.
Spider-Man 2.0
Fans of Donald Glover know that he kind of
campaigned to play Spider-Man in a big-screen
adaptation of the comic books.
"And then someone put a big picture of me
in the comments and was like, 'Donald Glover
could play Spider-Man!
He's nerdy!'"
His interest in the role prompted Spider-scribe
Brian Michael Bendis to create a new Spider-Man
inspired by Glover named Miles Morales.
And while Glover never made it to the big
screen as Spidey, he did voice the character
of Miles Morales on the Ultimate Spider-Man
animated series in 2015.
Glover returned to the Spidey-verse in Homecoming
as Aaron Davis, a career criminal with the
alias of "Prowler," according to Spider-Man's
files.
Sure, Marvel's main Prowler is some guy named
Hobie, but in the Ultimate Universe, it's
a guy named Aaron Davis.
His nephew?
A guy named Miles Morales, the very same nephew
that Prowler refers to during his parking
garage confrontation with Spider-Man.
And if that wasn't confirmation enough, check
out his license plate: UCS-M01, which is short
for Ultimate Comics, Spider-Man #1.
Karen
Once Spider-Man has accessed his suit's full
capabilities, he's treated to a very JARVIS-like
computer which is able to cater to his every
need, which he names Karen.
Avengers fans know that within the MCU, JARVIS
is Tony Stark's personal computer, which then
merged with a robot body, becoming Vision.
Along the way, JARVIS was always played by
Paul Bettany, even as the Infinity Stone-wielding
Vision.
In real life, Bettany is married to Jennifer
Connelly, who plays the voice of Karen in
Homecoming, keeping the pair of companion
computer programs as close as the people who
actually play them.
True to the page
One of Spidey's most memorable scenes came
in Amazing Spider-Man #33.
The comic's cover spells out Spidey's peril
pretty clearly, and it's nearly identical
to the scene in Homecoming when Vulture causes
the roof to cave in on Parker.
For five pages, Spider-Man struggles under
wet rubble, thinking of his responsibilities
as the wall-crawler… and that gives him
the strength to set himself free.
It's pretty much comic book perfect.
Credits due
Blink and you'll miss it among the countless
scrawls of graffiti decorating Peter Parker's
New York City, but eagle-eyed viewers have
spotted the word 'Bagley' emblazoned amid
the colorful chaos.
Mark Bagley is noted in the Marvel Comics
universe for being a huge contributor to Spider-Man,
co-creating the villain Carnage, and illustrating
Venom's early turn as an anti-hero in the
Venom: Lethal Protector miniseries, so his
quick mention is no mistake.
And casual comic fans might be left wondering
why Jack Kirby is given any credit at all
for Spider-Man during the film's credits sequence,
since Spidey is one of the few 1960s comic
characters that Kirby was never really associated
with.
Comics history reveals that Kirby and Lee
sat down together to come up with Spider-Man,
and Kirby even drew the first batch of pages
for the hero, using his own designs, before
Lee rejected the concept and changed it a
bit to fit his own vision.
Kirby ended up pencilling just the covers
of Spidey's debut in Amazing Fantasy #15 as
well as Amazing Spider-Man #1, before moving
on to other projects, but his impact on Spider-Man
being acknowledged by Marvel is a pretty big
deal.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!